five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
genius brain podcast how is everybody
doing how was your weekend how was your
week day yeah man it's been cold as [ __ ]
in LA it's raining the water is coming
down it feels great
we need it though we need it that's
about that's basically the conversation
that everybody has in LA yeah
hey man it's raining a lot oh we need it
oh yeah like okay we get it
we [ __ ] yeah okay there's no rate a
lot in LA yeah it's like yeah man like
okay we were to drought all right I
gotta go cool
yeah man and yeah sometimes when it
rains like um I feel like nobody knows
how to drive here yeah yeah people don't
know how to drive yep yeah man so um I
gotta go dude I can't hold on hold on
what kind of Asian are you man the bad
guy no the bad guy that's so high I
expected that much out of you yeah so
today's guest is the the the caramel
skinned flappy eared big-lipped tiny
eyed spiky haired when I smile my eyes
disappear questionable sweater dude this
is one of my favorite sweaters oh it's
great I love Tiffany got this for me for
Christmas
TIFF and she was gonna return it but I
loved it a lot can I say this TIFF you
have great taste you have a terrible
boyfriend she's not boyfriend she has
said she has really good taste in
clothes and anything vintage and she has
an eye for four for that kind of stuff
but she does have terrible taste in men
yes 100% I agree with that a thousand
percent yeah like I'm sure I don't know
if you think this but for all the all
the homies out there that have a
significant other do you ever wonder
what your significant other sees in you
it's [ __ ] this guy right now I'm that
guy I think about that a lot I just
can't put my finger on it but you don't
know but it's not it's not like I know
exactly what Muriel see
me I'm a fantastic [ __ ] guy yeah
whatever dude did I'm great I'm a
[ __ ] catch dude you're just you're
just rich and you have a huge dick dude
that's all that matters I'll tell you
this the dick is average and I'm
absolutely poor but but she sticks
around yeah so she's so she's kind of
the shoes that like you know that my my
lady is in I'll tell you this I'm a
fantastic man and she knows exactly what
she got into and in fact I actually lost
weight
so she upgraded yeah no you did you want
to talk about how much weight you lost
about how much how much weight did you
lose
I lost 60 pounds dude since I first met
you it's [ __ ] sick okay don't you
drink my [ __ ] waters more [ __ ]
trash bin yeah you know what if this
filter is very good yeah look at you
just drinking that [ __ ] nice and quiet I
like that I'm gonna have to pee in like
ten minutes all right well let's get
this podcast done but son of a [ __ ] but
uh yeah you lost a lot of weight you
lost 60 pounds I lost 60 solid pounds it
was one of the most difficult things
I've done in the first two months after
the first two months nicest Eddie but
think about how much better you feel in
your day-to-day activities
yeah man I mean I think that the weight
loss thing here's a thing too especially
when we talk about this thing
the-the-the the big people movement
that's been going on right now and this
is coming on from somebody who has been
fat his whole life there's a substantial
difference and I feel like I know this
has been like beat over a lot of
people's head heads but there is a
difference between loving yourself and
then being out of shape and I think that
when I when I see a lot of like the
hashtag big people move in and you know
to their to their credit what they're
saying is that there's a certain
societal standard of what people should
look like and because people look a
certain way or they're supposed to
quote-unquote look a certain way to
because they're attractive a lot of
people you know look down on them which
does happen a lot but the problem that I
think that I see a lot and this is like
I said this comes from somebody who was
big his whole life is that you can't
convince me that physically I you you
feel better being bigger than you would
if you lost some weight
yeah and it's not even being about being
really big but it's
being unhealthy yeah and having you know
the possibility of having a better
quality of life yeah that's what it's
really about and then not only are you
affecting yourself but you're affecting
the people around you yeah it you know I
always see this too especially with some
of my friends who are on Instagram and
they are bigger right we were all big
and consistently I always see on their
post they go I love the way they look I
love the way that I am you know if you
really did write and I know these people
too because they struggled with their
weight a lot and they're always
constantly trying to lose weight and
they're like I'm perfectly beautiful
nobody said that you [ __ ] weren't
nobody none of our friends like you you
clearly don't have like a public account
so who the [ __ ] is telling you that
you're not beautiful it's not us Yeah
right it's not the people that matter in
your life that are telling you that
that's that's something that you're
struggling with yourself and the thing
about that is and I always mention that
the hardest part about fitness is people
being honest with themselves it's like
if you don't like the way you look then
you have the ability to change it but if
you keep trying to convince yourself
that you're happy with the way that you
are when you're not that's where it's
gonna mentally [ __ ] you up yeah and I
keep seeing these posts constantly and
it's just this long diatribe you see on
Instagram and everybody sees that [ __ ]
right and no one's gonna read it yeah
absolutely not you read the first three
sentences maybe and then you get the
gist of it yeah but do you feel like
anybody kind of looked down on you after
you lost a lot of weight no I think a
lot of people got inspired to lose
weight themselves which is great no
one's like I miss the fat David oh I
missed the fat David too though
sometimes that David was pretty [ __ ]
cool man it's just fat David was dying
and you know fat David was dying see
that's the thing that people don't think
about as well is that they don't think
about the consequences of their health
yeah and it just seems so far away that
they're just not worried about it but
it's really sad that it takes a lot of
people something like a traumatic event
in their lifetime
yeah where they're like well kind of
change now yeah you know cuz they don't
think and I'm guilty of this as well
like you don't think
that's gonna be you until happens to you
yeah and and sometimes too even when
something terrible happens to them I
mean because it's such a mental thing if
you go the opposite way they'd just be
like well [ __ ] it this is this is this
is my life
you know that's gonna be me forever yeah
you know and they're not trying to
better themselves and it's it's it's
almost easier for you to say [ __ ] it
well this is that yeah and this is who I
am this is what it's gonna be
for me I would almost be okay with
somebody understanding the the concept
of being big is unhealthy and they're
just gonna be like this is how I want to
live my life then cool that would be
easier for me to handle then me having
to sit around and have a conversation
with somebody and keep telling me they
keep telling me that I'm healthy I'm
healthy I was like yeah that's that's
that's rough because not only especially
if they have a platform yeah and it
enables other people to kind of feel
that yeah and and they keep convoluting
the concept of being healthy and happy
right so they keep trying to attach this
this unhealthy lifestyle as saying oh
I'm fit and I'm also a hundred pounds
overweight yeah like that's where it
becomes something where I I've never
ever said that you know even as a big
guy I had I had you know my friends know
this - my self-esteem was perfectly fine
like I felt I loved myself consistently
throughout being a big guy my whole life
but what did you tell me when you first
started training to me you were telling
me that you didn't even know you were a
fat guy yeah I didn't always thought
other people were like oh man that guy's
fat yeah and then it took Mariel to say
oh like like you're a fat person yeah
and and that's the biggest problem with
with a lot of this issue is that people
don't associate these symptoms that
they're going through every day and
they're not associating that with bad
health yeah like we were talking about
how people are like oh yeah I have
diarrhea every day yeah and when it's
diary everyday it's just called poop
straight up it's and your poops aren't
supposed to be that way and that is a
sign of poor gut health or poor
digestive health or list goes on and on
of all these potential symptoms and
these are red flags that people don't
think about yeah you know you falling
asleep at like
2:00 p.m. after you eat lunch that sign
is a bad sign it's not support like and
you don't have to be a big guy to go
through that yeah like I was going
through that too until I hired my own
coaches to keep me accountable for
whatever I'm doing and as soon as they
started changing all that for me and as
soon as they kind of showed me the like
like yeah you need to be more conscious
of what you're eating because to me when
I'm eating I'm just eating a lot of
times and this happens to everybody most
of the time yeah is that what you're
just eating just eating and then you
know you're distracting you're on your
phone you're you're watching TV you're
doing work whatever but you're not
connecting to the food and then you're
not associating these feelings that you
have a few eat yeah ordering you're
eating and then it becomes a bigger
issue food is highly addictive and
that's the thing I couldn't really like
wrap my head around yeah you know
because I I just thought you know
everybody has to I can't not eat you
know and the the problem with the way
that I was thinking was number one I
couldn't tell when I was full number two
I couldn't tell when I was just
completely satiated yeah and I didn't
know the difference
exactly and people eat like cuz there's
this really good podcast I listen to and
um thanks for shouting out another
podcast on my pot yes you [ __ ]
it's called it's called better than
genius brain yeah it's called better
than gene it was a fitness podcast and
they they put it because the reason why
I bring this up is because it was the
podcast called cuz I wanna listen to it
it's called mind pump and one of the
guys that runs it I guess or one of the
guys there's three guys and they're all
they have beautiful information one of
them is like one of my online coaches
yeah him and his girlfriend they're
great was I gonna say yeah anyway so but
they talk about this all the time where
you actually have to connect to your
food like you don't they you never I
told her y'all gonna say see that what
you did right there you that's a [ __ ]
you you rat me in yeah and then you lost
me I lost you on that yeah you got me
there though yeah you got me there now
now real be back in you son of a [ __ ]
so the thing about most things is okay
we're just gonna say look at me when
life hits you in the face
right you got to ring that Bell and when
that bell rings guess what sometimes
God's gonna come in your ear yeah God
whispers in your ear you got to listen
guess what happens when God whispers in
your ear oh nothing nothing kind of like
what I did to you right now exactly yeah
so but you're talking about how I'm
sorry for being like connected to your
food and what you're eating now we
weren't talking about that okay what
that's all we're talking about yeah
sorry
um but they are always talking about
that concept and it took me for a while
to kind of like they would say try
eating a meal without drinking in your
water yeah and that's really [ __ ]
tough because sometimes you have to you
have to really chew your food yeah
and it takes you a really long time to
chew your food sometimes yeah and
sometimes you're just eating eating
eating and then you're like oh man like
you got like hiccups and [ __ ] you're
like on eat or drink water now yeah to
kind of help you like wash it down yeah
but you not properly eating your food
will equal poor gut health yeah
poor digest I literally don't chew yeah
- why would you shoot I eat like a
[ __ ] duck dude like literally chop
and then I just throw it right down the
[ __ ] corner your nose goes the
ceiling my stomach hates me because I
make it do too much work
yeah look won't you help me out to use
your [ __ ] teeth you fat [ __ ] and
you're like nope nah man you got to have
you lift nah man
duck style baby the sidelines you know
that's life you do it you do it I'm not
gonna do it why would I do
duck style baby I get this comment out
before well I'm talking to somebody and
that's it and and just being conscious
more aware of what you are eating how
you're feeling from a day-to-day
standpoint was a big was a was a was a
big you know I opening experience yes it
was thank you for to finish that for me
yeah I got you dude he doesn't know how
to speak English yes we've been here for
so long it's been [ __ ] 15 minutes you
got a [ __ ] but should I even bring up
the the first half well that's because
the first half you [ __ ] up yeah
yeah yeah forgot the [ __ ] erase the
card you piece of trash yeah I am I'm
running David's podcast that's right I
know what these are these are can't even
run your own Instagram dude you try to
run my own run the podcast dude I
installed these lights in here I you
know yeah you did a lot of things I
didn't do it this first time I caused
you grief dude you are you are a thief
of joy that's exactly what so we got
caught my eyes so I'm ignoring you right
which is probably what I deserve yeah
but anyways yeah when I that that
disconnected food was really big I
watched this documentary is just called
food I think that's what it's just
called but dump him yeah it's a really
stupid name I'm just getting shoutouts
of food you guys documentary not not
what you eat but they kind of go through
the different ways that food is I guess
you could say is I mean cooking is
basically a form of alchemy right like
baking is you take something and you
turn it into something else and but they
kind of go through the different
processes of how to cook food whether
it's with fire whether it's like baking
or like stealing something in a liquid
but one of the biggest takeaways that I
took from that documentary was how
people expect to eat food when they
consume it meaning that a lot of the
foods that we have are that people
consume on a daily basis it's very high
in calories very low nutrition yeah it's
hyper palatable yeah and and there are
our literal food scientists creating the
most addictive kind of food where your
body can't register it and you're just
eating it you're eating it you're eating
it and a lot of like fitness
professionals will say like try getting
try overeating on potatoes yeah
overeating rice yeah you won't and steak
and vegetables you won't because as soon
as you're done eating that you're like
well I'm done I don't I don't want to
eat anymore like they then yeah eat
[ __ ] a potato chip how easy is it oh
I can go through a bag of potato chips
like nothing yeah and and then at the
end of it it's like huh
give or take what is that like a bag of
potato chips a big king-size bag of
Doritos what is that like
maybe a thousand calories yeah exactly
and then you can you eat 3000 calories
of yeah no yeah and like the what we're
finding to or what people have been
knowing for a long time is that these
foods that have more calories in it that
are I guess quote-unquote bad for you
have a very low level of satiation like
they don't station at you very well nope
right and so like I started reading up
different types of food that satiate you
or like apples or something alright like
try to eat [ __ ] for apples I
if you eat [ __ ] for apples you're a
serial killer yeah how about that you're
a sociopath yeah get the [ __ ] out of my
face I've never seen somebody eating
more than past one banana in my life and
but like slow and yeah like when I eat
bananas I any fast you literally don't
need teeth for that so you're welcome
stomach well circle baby yeah and so
when I watch that it comes out the same
way as well they the person that they
were interviewing in the documentary
what they were saying was hey how about
you they said this okay you know what
you want to eat the foods that you like
to eat right cool if you want to eat
those type of foods I want you to make
it from scratch and what I mean yeah
and what I mean by that is like not even
getting the byproduct of what you need
in the greens in the grow it yourself
how do you make bread you [ __ ] grown
wheat exactly all right and then [ __ ]
grind that [ __ ] like I don't know what I
don't like yeah I kinda know how to make
bread this is how you make bread you
[ __ ] grow wheat you wait til that
[ __ ] dries out and it's nice and golden
you pick those little wheat seeds yeah
you stick it into a mill attach it to a
[ __ ] donkey that rotates around
grinds into a powder so I have to raise
his donkey somehow yeah yeah and we're
gonna get a donkey in the middle of you
know I don't [ __ ] know in Los Angeles
and then you'll do that and then you
take that then you make bread out of it
with water and eggs from the chicken but
you don't have the hamburger meat that's
right so I'm gonna raise that Cal you
got to raise that cow yeah then you
gotta kill it
yep then you have to grind it which is
probably going to lettuce the vegetables
so there's there's a huge process in
order to eat a food like that that we
have constantly readily available at our
fingertips and then the sad part about
it is is once you get all those
ingredients and you have it ready to go
you don't even want a hamburger yeah I
don't want it I don't [ __ ] want this
this labor burger that's what I should
is do this
and this is a waste of time but now you
go to Burger King and you could get it
right there for a dollar fifty yeah but
you could also get fries a cookie and
exactly so these schools that are these
fools these foods that are readily
available our stuff that number one
doesn't satiate you very well and it
shouldn't be that available for you to
eat all the [ __ ] time and it's
surrounded like we're surrounded by it
yeah like you try to eat healthy good
luck yeah because it's hard you're
bombarded with and a lot of people are
like what are healthy foods and we're so
disconnected with what healthy foods are
where we can even like I've been there
that's I'm speaking from experience yeah
I'll decide if type of stuff by the way
when I mentioned this is stuff that blew
my [ __ ] mind I had no [ __ ] idea
but then and then you realize that like
oh [ __ ] this is what the cycle I've been
going through yeah you know like this is
like when I'm trying to get lunch I have
to really think about what I'm gonna eat
yeah because I need something that's
gonna be somewhat healthy I need to know
that the food is you know not gonna [ __ ]
me up for the rest of the day it's not
gonna affect my training it's not gonna
affect how I work throughout the day
it's it has to and I'm like hey where am
I gonna get this at a reasonable price
yeah do I have time to sit down at a
restaurant yeah do I have time to go
home and cook and like all these these
obstacles make it really easy when you
see if Wendy's down the street which is
also very delicious yeah very satiating
for the most part yeah on a taste level
yeah but not on a micronutrient level
yeah and then you eat it
and then then it goes on the cycle of
you just feeling like [ __ ] but you're
like oh well hunger again I'm gonna go
Oh burn Kings here perfect what I found
to for for myself when I was eating at
home versus eating out I always tend to
eat less when I ate at home but I was
eating healthier food yeah and the
reason why is because when I full yeah
I'm full and I could stop whenever I
want and it's in the fridge so I can go
ahead and grab it whenever yeah when I
when I'm at a restaurant I feel almost
pressure that I have to eat the whole
[ __ ] thing and you don't yeah you
have to clear clean your plate and
that's what we've been trained as kids
yeah is like clear plate clear and plate
and it's so hard for me to be at a
restaurant and either not eat the little
bit of rice or whatever I have left on
my plate mm-hmm and it could be a small
amount yeah
but part of me is like I gotta [ __ ]
eat it yeah and then my girlfriend my
fiancee now if she's a pretty small
eater I end up eating her food too
yeah and it's like I don't want her
waste that do people would say some
foreign s worse to me dude they're like
dude just take it for leftovers of the
whole thing what's the leftover like you
know take the food and bring it home I
like no that doesn't exist what's that
what's the [ __ ] leftover yeah like I
don't [ __ ] out of my face what did you
call me yeah and then I fight them yeah
and then I robbed them yeah and then we
make up and then we have sex yeah at
dessert that's how we became friends
yeah that's the sex with David so that
you go record but because he had
leftovers I got so mad yeah and I was
like no I have a bag I'm gonna take you
put it in my fridge and he's like what
the [ __ ] you [ __ ] dare let's have sex
and I was like what okay
yeah cut to now what's up but that was
the the biggest there was so many
[ __ ] things that were blowing my
[ __ ] mind that I had no idea about
like how I used to consider it's right
under her nose the whole time yeah and I
had to put my finger there yes you did
you know what I'm literally right under
your foot right under your nose a
mustache like that dirty little must and
I will never grow yeah because I don't
my choice yeah but like I think like
when it came to certain you know pieces
of information that just seems so common
sense it just I just couldn't apply it
and I think that's the biggest thing
that I would that I did out of
everything as I took the time to learn
and kind of accept the things that I was
reading as truth and knowledge and and
that's the difference between you losing
this weight and somebody that you know
would struggle with this yeah is the
open-mindedness of this whole process
yeah on top of the fact that you know
you have to do your own research or you
know if you have somebody that's really
there that's there to guide you and to
put you through this a lot of the times
is you won't take it as gospel and you
shouldn't you shouldn't take what
they're saying all the time
as the truth yeah because you have to do
your own research because there's a lot
of people that don't know what they're
talking about yeah that just kind of say
[ __ ] just to say [ __ ] yeah you know like
I see it all the time from other
trainers or whatever we mean some other
changes were talking about that today of
how we see trainers talk to their
clients about [ __ ] they're just
making stuff up yeah about like the
reason why your muscles are sore or or
or why you should eat this type of food
you know it goes the list goes on so if
you have somebody that's guiding you
through this process of you losing
weight or gaining weight you should be
doing your own research 100% of the time
yeah and you'll find they're either full
of [ __ ] or they're like oh man that
guy's pretty small a lot of the times
like the problem is that when people do
their own research and they are finding
these answers I feel like a lot of
people because I was in this position as
well is that we don't want to find the
answers that'll that'll give us pain or
discomfort we want to live comfortably
as possible and we want to get this we
want to get the results that we want and
it doesn't work that way
everybody's looking for the homerun yeah
everybody's looking for that and I've
I've been there to where I'm looking for
a specific answer in like a certain like
a research topic or so I buy someone's
program or I read someone's article and
then I'm sitting there thinking but like
that doesn't answer my question
yeah because it's the answers in between
the lines like it's it's not no one can
give you the direct answer to you know
what you're looking for a lot of the
time because application is everything -
and you're really never going to know
what's going to work for you unless you
try it and I think a lot of people -
because they are they have failed so
much in trying a diet they're so scared
of that they're so scared of failure and
they'd rather find the excuse not to do
something because at least before they
could it's the same concept of when
dudes um they get rejected by a girl
right so so they'll they'll be hauling
out a girl yeah what's up mama how you
doing the girl goes I don't know like
you and they go yes you ugly anyway
exactly it was the defense mechanism
yeah and that's the same concept that
people have when it comes to that's why
your teeth crooked this yeah
whatever bid your [ __ ] smells like you
even get that close to it how'd you
smell it yeah but but what if it what if
he did small yes sir she's like whatever
you just [ __ ] no it's like seriously
ma'am you're I'm a gynecologist and your
[ __ ] smells it's yes there's something
wrong yeah I'm not hitting on you I'm
saying you need to go to a hospital now
very arrogant of you to just think that
I was like my mother's cooking fish
sauce haha stinky tofu baby yeah and you
know it's it's that constant just fear
failure like like when everybody asked
you David what did you do to lose to
wait oh wait I bet they were kind of
disappointed when you were like oh I
just walked every day yeah they were and
they kept trying to find their like
answers but what was it really yeah it's
like I walked every day I walked every
day and that worked for you yeah that
was that's something that I recommend to
a lot of my clients they're just trying
to get more active and they're trying to
you know try to increase that metabolism
is just walk get a little more activity
a day and that's an easy thing that for
all the listeners out there there people
are trying to lose some weight
what just are walking it's it's it's the
little goes a long way it really does
and it but it's it's the biggest it but
but people think that it just it's oh
it's exercise that's what's gonna help
me get there but it's not it's it's the
habit-forming yeah it's the routine it's
making a ritual it's it's starting in
you you get the momentum rolling and
then it carries over to all these other
things in your life where you started
exercising more you started eating
cleaner but you're a special type of
individual where you probably when you
put your mind to something you just
[ __ ] do it yeah I think like you know
but I failed so many times before and I
did exactly and I when I was a cop-out
answer I had half an answer saying that
like oh you will you're this kind of
person
yes it's not yeah it's that plus
everything else yeah like I failed so
many times before and the reason why was
because I kept on looking for a quick
answer I kept telling myself that yo I'm
gonna lose his weight in three months
imma loses weight in four months and I
always put a time limit on when I was
supposed to lose this weight and I and
the biggest disappointing thing that I
did was I looked at other people's
results and what they were getting out
of life or whatever their fitness
program was and I wanted to get what
they had
versus doing it based on on myself and
the knowledge that I should be gaming
and I kept on looking for quick answers
there and when it turned out was that
instead of looking for a quick answer
I should just be finding answers in
general yeah and I had to do that
research and one of the biggest thing
that I found out was number one I don't
have a habit like I keep failing because
I would only last at and I would go so
[ __ ] extreme dude I'm talking about I
would go to the gym and I will [ __ ]
ham dude and Bart would always tell me
the same [ __ ] that [ __ ] you up for how
long yeah I would go balls to the
[ __ ] wall and I'm like I can do this
and then I won't go to the gym for
probably like two weeks because I
exploded my quads yeah I was just dying
and then it puts you deeper in a hole
yeah because you're that's one day you
worked out now in the span of two weeks
yeah you probably went one day yeah you
know and and on top of that it's like
you need to have a consistency yeah
especially with all the the New Year's
resolutions out there all the people
want to go [ __ ] crazy on their first
day and it's like no it doesn't work
that way yeah and the smarter idea would
be for you to just be frequent with the
low with a low level so more frequency
less intensity is what I always say
right yeah and intensity is is a tool
that has to be managed and you have to
use it intermittently like you have to
do it at the right time and but for a
lot of times you just need to get the
ball rolling if you don't work out
consistently yeah you need to do
something that you can get moving
something low level where you know you
can do like yeah if you can't see
yourself doing it for rest of your life
that's probably not gonna work for you
that long yeah and like with frequency
to the the cool thing is is that it just
teaches you that you could accomplish
something on a daily basis and what it
also teaches you to it's that these
results will come slower but they'll
last a lot longer a hundred percent and
I've I've kept this weight off for quite
a while and I'm still losing weight here
and there but my weight loss has been
more stagnant now obviously I'm getting
closer to that goal but I've also
stopped doing those walks and those
walks were the biggest thing that was
helping me lose weight it wasn't
something I was just saying as if it's
the the easiest answer for weight loss
but like I'm walking three to four miles
a day yes and it became habit that I
enjoyed it a lot and that goes for the
same habit of eating healthy food and
people don't realize that you're
actually
dicted to these foods that are terrible
for you and you think that it tastes
amazing because you're addicted to that
substance it's that same concept of
smoking a [ __ ] cigarette you eat a
bowl of raspberries and then you eat a
bowl of gummy bears
yeah the gummy bears are always gonna
taste better yeah you know but you have
to get in a rhythm and yeah and a
consistency with your food where you
start to crave these types of foods like
it's crazy I never thought like dude I'm
the biggest [ __ ] sweet tooth of all
time yeah I eat and I eat any kind of
candy I'm always eating it I'm anything
anything I'm like I'm a fiend for it but
now I'm at a point where it took me a
while it took me a little bit but I I
like eating raspberries and I eat that
as a snack that's my candy now yeah but
will I [ __ ] go bananas on on a bag of
gummy worms or something like that and I
will but people do I feel like [ __ ]
afterwards I am
people underestimate the human body and
how smart it is it's trying to adapt all
the time so whatever you put in front of
it it will adapt to it if you get a
consistency of you eating clean healthy
foods your body will crave it and
sometimes you'll crave a [ __ ] salad
which is crazy but yeah when you eat
something really terrible that's not
really ideal for your body yeah you're
gonna be like [ __ ] I wish I had a salad
instead yeah and that tells you that
you're in a good place
like health-wise like as far as your
inner rhythm of because this is a
consistency like your body's very smart
and it knows what it wants and that's
the thing I underestimated B most is
that I didn't really trust that I
thought like I knew what I wanted more
than what my body knew right so when I
would eat these help quote unquote
healthy foods which is good food it's
just stuff I just didn't eat on the
regular I thought it tasted bad and
that's also because what I also find out
is I never gave myself an opportunity to
actually be hungry I don't know what
hungry was yeah you know like I was
never really hungry I always had some
type of food readily available whether
it was from post mates whether I could
just drive a couple miles out and eat a
hefty meal and I just didn't want to be
hungry or I just didn't
think it was something that I needed to
feel how many times have you eaten
something out of like boredom oh all the
[ __ ] time you like almost exclusively
there was a point in time where
especially after I think after I started
in like fighting and I would get I would
do weight cuts and then since you're
depriving yourself so much of food this
is when I kind of developed like a weird
relationship with food where this was
like the food porn days were well it's
still kind of like that now but like the
Guy Fieri's dollars and drive-ins and
dives
yeah you'd watch that you'd be like oh
man they're putting [ __ ] dumped in
cheese on everything they're putting
butter on everything you're like oh my
god so while you're like depriving
yourself of nutrients and trying to
starve yourself to lose like 15 pounds
in like two weeks or whatever though
what I was doing I would write a list of
all the foods that I want to eat and
yeah but then afterwards I would go
[ __ ] crazy
yeah like till almost pretty much till I
made myself sick and it [ __ ] my body
up and it's I'm still kind of paying for
it a little bit yeah
where I just can't stop craving these
types of foods and that became the only
food I eat yeah was pizzas and [ __ ]
in and out and and all the crazy food
trucks with you know yeah yeah yeah with
three cheeseburgers on it with but you
see this right so like I'll see this
stuff on Instagram and people will send
me stuff they go doesn't this look bomb
I'm like dude that looks [ __ ] disgust
amen yeah and then when you eat it
it tastes like [ __ ] yeah it just tastes
like fat on top of fat it's like oh yeah
this food truck or this restaurant is
doing this we're gonna one-up it
somebody sent me this video of a
hamburger that was stuffed it was like
like four patties with four pieces of
cheese which is fine and then they put
hot cheetos on it on the inside and they
crumble hot cheese and they poured
melted hot cheese on it she's and the
first thing I thought was that doesn't
look good to me
that gives me the answer for everything
it doesn't look like it tastes good what
the [ __ ] are you saying and this
particular don't doesn't that look bomb
I'm like in what [ __ ] world does that
look like that you eat two bites of that
done good luck yeah you're [ __ ] your
pants throw a hump yeah and that's not
me being a food I'm saying like arguably
it just doesn't look tasty today the
burner look fine
and has itself and then but after a
while you see all that and then you you
kind of seen it all
yeah you you've seen like have you seen
the cotton candy uh like burrito no what
have you seen that so it like people
take a cotton candy and then they put
ice cream they put like now I already
don't want it and they roll it up and
it's but it's like what ice cream pretty
sweet look but then I'm gonna put cotton
candy around it
sugar just like spun of sugar you know
and it's like what do you want me to do
with this yeah I was it but people go
crazy over it and it's like it's like a
thing on the internet where people are
like oh my god that looks so good yeah
that all's they say that that was the
hardest part that people didn't
understand especially when like I joined
forces to start up that saucers place
right when we had customers that were
saying like oh like what other toppings
do you have I'm like there aren't other
toppings this officer is artisanal
meaning that I we created this so it's
gonna taste a certain way and we're not
gonna add 17 Snickers on top of it we're
not gonna add Froot Loops and Cheerios
and all this other [ __ ] because it
doesn't make sense and you're not gonna
be able to taste it like you want that
stuff because somebody told you that
this is the epitome of what what a good
tasting piece of dessert is yeah and
it's not and and I it's it's not us
being snobby it's more like we are we
want you to have an experience with this
if you wanted to just put a bunch of
[ __ ] on it you could just do that at
home and you shouldn't pay for that type
of stuff you should pay for something
that you're getting something out of it
right so if we're gonna serve something
to you like we thought really hard on it
and it's like I said it's not snobbery
it's not that you're wrong or anything
else like that it's just this is what
we're serving and I hope you like it and
if you don't that's a hundred percent
okay so your food palette is [ __ ] that's
what David is really trying to say no
absolutely not what I'm saying is that
this is how we want to serve it and if
you don't like it you're allowed to have
that opinion and if you do have that
opinion just don't put it on Yelp and go
[ __ ] yourself
yeah I'm just kidding but I've had
people come in in the ex day asking and
we explained to them nicely like yo this
is how the flavor is yeah I hope you
like it if you don't let us know and
then we'll just refund you the money
that's okay it's all good man like
everybody is allowed to have their
opinion and one fine
with that and that's the great thing
about food why do you think
baskin-robbins has 31 flavors oh there's
there's gonna be something for everybody
and they are everywhere yeah because you
could always find something that you
like yeah you know but it's not like the
best ice cream yeah and I like it a lot
yeah but and I don't want to do
something that I don't I don't want to
start something that I don't personally
like doesn't get you excited yeah and it
why would you do with them and it's also
just buying into the whole type of just
the food addiction thing which I'm
really I say I'm against because it did
take away a good few years of my life
that was quality years of my life you
know that I could have had that could
have been arguably better okay
and then how much of your your time or
your day was consumed on like trying to
like eat all these crazy foods yeah that
it became that and that was the same
thing for like I would eat as if I would
never be allowed to eat it again all I
dude I wouldn't make eye contact with
anybody yeah and I would just stuff my
[ __ ] face and I'd eat a lot yeah and
I'm still kind of paying for it like
yeah I feel like kind of I felt like
[ __ ] for a while and I'm finally in a
rhythm where I'm like oh man this is
what you're supposed to feel like
yeah I'm not supposed to be falling
asleep at the wheel at like 2:00 o'clock
yeah and because now I like the biggest
food I think the food that I eat the
most is is shabu and the reason why is
shabu just has we just have some shabu
right now right before we did this it's
a high nutrition is really quick and
look how much energy we have yeah like
I'm not I don't have the itis yeah yeah
I mean I'm not falling asleep yeah you
know it's just very simple food that's
really good for me and it tastes really
good and after we ate it we ate a good
amount yeah but we didn't feel like [ __ ]
yeah oh great yeah and that's how you
kind of should feel after you eat food
yeah like that that's the connection
that most people should have oh here's
another tip for people who are trying to
if your new year's goal is to lose
weight if you eat food and you instantly
feel sleepy you've already [ __ ] up
like you have you definitely didn't use
or eat the food for energy
you ate it to just stuff your [ __ ]
face keep it to whole natural foods
who's that you know grow out of the
ground
yeah they fly they swim
run those types of things you should be
consuming yeah
Oh a little too soon there aren't we oh
yeah dude but it's it's that's all we've
been watching did you watch all six
episodes crazy dude it's one of the
funniest documentaries I've ever seen
I'm sorry but it's wait where are you
going with this it's funny what's your
angle it's funny because the documentary
should have been called I knew
everything but I didn't say [ __ ] yeah
that's what the documentary should have
been called and that's why I was
laughing so [ __ ] much because every
yo like what if they talked to his
buddies and they're like yeah we knew
something was up but like I don't know
it was all that oh come on
[ __ ] it yo you know what the worst part
was was when there was these parents
that were up there right and she she was
kind of like she was kind of hood
because she straight up said she goes
miss they I could tell that the camera
person or the person that was
interviewing them asked them what they
would do if they saw our Kylie can I
guess who would come parent you're
talking about yeah
were they the ones at the end of the
documentary that was saying it was the
mom that said if I see our Kelly out in
the streets is on a pop yeah it's all
sight it's all sight yeah it was like
yeah I get it
she'll see us I've been to prison before
and I'm afraid to go get all I have but
as a parent you know like I'm not a
parent but like I can only imagine like
yeah for sure
but me [ __ ] throwing down like I'm
like I don't know the situation but they
were the worst parents to me because
number one the [ __ ] took it to
the r.kelly concert he brought her up on
stage and then he was like well I knew
about his past but you know that stuff
was all hearsay sheshe was he started
dancing on her right yeah but it's just
that's a crazy move yeah and I thought
to myself like don't they plant like
women in the audience so he could pull
out so [ __ ] like that it doesn't happen
because she was underage right she was
super underage and on top of that there
turns knew who that was his back and he
was like oh why did I'll [ __ ]
I didn't think it was like a problem I
was like first of all you knew it was a
problem but you saw an opportunity for
your daughter to become somebody famous
and you wanted to take that and then
finally when it got out of control then
you were like hold on a second mr. Kelly
you can't come up and do this to my kid
only because the opportunity of her
you see her disappeared yeah so get the
[ __ ] on out of here with that [ __ ]
and now you're trying to do the whole
sob story thing
you [ __ ] up as a parent that's what it
was that's a red flag
you chose you're a possibility for your
daughter to be famous over the safety of
your daughter it's how I felt I don't
know as I seem like I feel like as a
parent you know I don't yeah once again
I don't know either
I don't I don't have kids but I do have
a beautiful dog of a couple dogs okay
that's the same thing yeah same thing
same thing so it's so upsetting people
are like what the [ __ ] cancel this guy
cancel cancel culture cancel Nick yeah
get rid of me please somebody how
somebody needs to but like if that was
your daughter yeah as a as a man and you
see I don't care who it is
well there's our Kelly or not yeah like
you know grind up on your daughter
absolutely now I would be livid a 40
year old man at that 45 year old man at
that I would be so livid yeah you know
and he was just like oh no I you know I
knew about him or not but you know you
seemed like it was like hearsay nothing
was really concrete and people were just
allegations it wasn't [ __ ]
allegations bro
you knew that [ __ ] you he knew about the
trial he knew everything else and he was
okay with his daughter dancing and when
it got out of hand and he knew that he
would his daughter wasn't gonna gain an
opportunity from this is when he started
questioning it she was trying to be a
singer yeah she was trying to be and she
was amazing biased I notice how I
watched the documentary but I was like
wait what one was she like I have no
idea like the dude it was wild when I
was watching that Dokken kind of like
how many parents [ __ ] up when they
knew everything and they're his team
that knew everything and didn't say
anything on top of that what's it called
his assistant was just there or the
person that used to work for him she was
the one that had like the the voice
modulation oh yeah everything and a
whole bunch of people were Koontz with
them the [ __ ] bodyguard that
threatened um that dude that dude is
running a [ __ ] crazy cult I heard
like the even the bodyguard is like in
it's like going to jail or some [ __ ] you
know I bet they're all I bet they were
all doing some sort of level of that
yeah you know like I just did you hear
Timberland statement where Timberland
was like yeah I it wasn't in the doc but
he kind of put out a statement where he
met alia and he said he fell in love
with her too but he knew better because
she was too young and
like bro don't say that out loud don't
say that to the press talk about the war
statement ever dude - what terrible
timing
dude that was he's kind of like saying
like well you know you would have you
would have done that - you would have
fallen in love with the LIA there was a
this is [ __ ] crazy on a Tim's channel
that he uploaded and a day like that oh
yeah he went to an art Kelly concert and
now it all makes sense because this is
clip of our Kelly on the stage and you
know like he's just like singing his
words and a girl's like wiping his sweat
down so he hands her a towel to wipe his
sweat down right and he's singing and he
goes why my face
she starts wiping his face he goes why
my tongue sticks out his tongue why my
body starts a lot wiping down his body
and then as she's laying wiping down his
chest in his body he start standing up
but he says she starts wiping down his
dick right to the dick and balls
right and he's just grinding it I was
like yo this is some real [ __ ]
it's him just [ __ ] getting his dick
rubbed by this girl if he goes grab my
dick and she starts grabbing his yeah no
that's that's something that I've heard
like not only have comedians talked
about that but yeah everybody that's a
real [ __ ] yeah yeah and you know power
to him because not all not power to him
but yeah you people people you know if
they're gonna do it if he's telling you
to do it and they're gonna do it you
know they don't want to be the girl that
didn't rub down our Kelly's tickle balls
when he commanded it on state did you
see then you look like you're no fun
that's right but did you see that clip
of him
in Ethiopia the Khans oh dude the song
he was singing do you want it was like
do you want to come back to me would you
like to come with prop to America
attitude and like it goes do you have
your passport did you get your shots
yeah would you like to come with prop to
America and the background comes in to a
bed like they have that planned out and
then it was that recent or was that a
while ago how it looked like he was
older but that's pretty [ __ ] funny
dude - and the level of planning in that
song is it's almost like he wanted to
get caught because he would hang around
high schools well he he that's that's a
song right it's perfect it's a
performance is this whole das thinking
this is Mary
Oh Muriel hello I'm doing a podcast
right now
hi Mary also I'm gonna have to call you
back okay what he's also said huh
oh I said hello I thought you sounded
sad that's why this is a couple life you
know
oh that was Nick Nick says hi hi okay
I'll talk to you later okay
bye surprised yeah that was the
girlfriend interrupting my work dude
ladies am i right freaking ladies right
am i right anyways that song he's
serious he's hoping somebody underage is
gonna come back with him to America from
Ethiopia and that way he could probably
doctor everything yeah you know you have
your passports foreign so people in
Ethiopia are like yeah they're foreign
clients is ridiculous lyrics ever do you
have your passport did you get your
shots would you like to come with Robin
to America's kind of catchy though do
they kind of get here data caching with
with those words you see that on paper
you're like no way that could be a song
and they all sings it you're like that's
that's the power of music it is dude
it's the power of music that's the power
of a black but only black people can
sing words that are random and to make
it still sound dopest foot especially an
arm being like oh yeah like yet head
that's exclusive that's exclusive to
that was some wild [ __ ] dude like just
watching first of all they did kind of
drag the documentary sure he's kind of
long like this episode could've been for
you know I didn't expect them to save
that girl but dude when they put two cuz
I they dropped a hint at the beginning
they're like yeah she's the tomboy yeah
and then when they show her on the TMZ
clip and then they circle and is zoom in
and I'm like holy [ __ ] but that is so
crazy how he groomed her to look that
way like a little boy yeah so I didn't
know he liked little boys either but
it's just uh-huh
dude I don't even I don't know what to
say you don't know to say somebody's
good I was telling my my lady today I
was like someone's probably gonna murder
him Mama's gonna shoot him someone's
gonna like because
I'm sure he's like a sex cult or some
[ __ ] yeah he's pissed off enough people
where they're like you know what if I
see this dude in the streets was on a
poppin it's weird because like sparkle
her she's so funny yeah sing to her
bangs are dope yo Sparkle when she had a
she would they were in court and the
young girl that was in that pissing
video yeah the one they got high like
fire hydrant that was Rosie's that the
street so you have the fire she got the
fire best BES you don't know the street
turns bro dude yeah dude she got the
happy sprinkler to the face is that what
they used in the in the court documents
that's right yeah she got the super
soaker to the face the super soaker 3000
oh man
that's exactly what happened that's
rough that's right but it's been long
enough yeah when she got smashed in the
face with the pp yeah like they just
straight yeah right denied it was her in
the video yeah she was the only one that
was like that's her but her parents were
the well thought her parents was heard
said her cousin
her brother said that's not her and
sparkle was just in shock and that's why
they lost that case probably right
that's what happened what didn't she
wouldn't say it was so she said That's
not me in the video and so that's why
the case was dropping and Cara Kelly got
away with this so either they were
handed off money like other than the
table under the table money or the
family would rather have her safe face
and I bet it's a combination of both I
bet it's mostly to save face I'll put it
to you like this right you're in a video
are Kelly [ __ ] you in the ass and
pissed in your face how Kelly goes mr.
Nick dude if I gave you $100,000 would
you not send me through J hey Hale I'll
say I'll do it for ten o dollars at the
time of my life ten solid dollars but
what really [ __ ] with me in those is
all the stories of the women and when
they talk about like the weird things he
did I'm like oh who don't a what
remember the girl that he slapped the
[ __ ] up because she she mentioned the
accusations of his of his baby touching
and [ __ ] but she actually didn't know
about which was kind of wild yeah but
she didn't know any about like come on
our Kelly trip
trip how did you not he see that [ __ ]
attitude she probably doesn't have a lot
that's that's that's your blocking here
mentally blocking it yeah it is she
didn't know him that she broke down and
then when they met up in person he
slapped the [ __ ] out of her dude
yeah that's it's just everything that
dude does is like oh you're a monster
yeah monster he's a [ __ ] monster even
if like 10 percent of it was true you're
like oh you're a piece of [ __ ] still
yeah you know like it's just like what
and it happens consistently and it's
it's so crazy how much you can get away
with yeah and he really is and he
defiled alia dude I know you were kind
of young for a little I don't really is
okay choosing Romi almost died
alright that's Jetley didn't even kiss
her in that movie you know but he kissed
her in the music video though yeah but
you know we watch that seeing one alia
song right now you know just the the
song about the passport ethiopia is the
only thing that's coming to my head
right now
you have your passport at dude because
that is touching my head and and i was
talking about my lady about this today i
was thinking about how people they want
to separate someone's like acts in their
real life yeah if they're art or
whatever right yeah
like say pablo picasso he's one that cut
his ear off right he's a crazy [ __ ] but
he's like oh man he made beautiful
masterpieces but he was hurting himself
yeah yeah that's one thing right yeah
exactly but my thing is at what point do
people stop giving that like what's the
word I'm looking for
just pass anymore yeah like what do you
have to do to like not get that pass do
it I don't know but people get hard with
like Usher
like I should put out a song about him
cheating and having a baby by somebody
else yeah and women still loved him
yeah good for him you know hold diva
confessions anybody or two nobody
listens to the lyrics like I was
listening to the I don't have an ugly
record in my car cuz I'm a sociopath I
guess cuz I want to pay for it
so I've been listening to radio uh-huh
yes not anymore oh dude it's so bad and
they literally have I've heard sicko
mode for maybe 72 times in the past
three days of course and I listen to it
all the way through because
a big fan but I don't you know I don't
like that like it but I do like it a lot
but all the songs that they play on that
on their radio yeah
our [ __ ] so bad yeah but you listen
to it enough where you're like I kind of
like it it gets stuck in your [ __ ]
man that's how they get you did and then
you're a part of it you're a part of
like oh I know the words this did you
know that he made um I forgot he wrote
that a very famous song for Michael
Jackson it was on that thing right
r.kelly I did yeah
there's a man in the mirror it wasn't
man on it it could have been yeah no he
he wrote you were not alone for for
Michael Jackson and the crazy thing is
Michael Jackson was also known as a baby
toucher which by the way wasn't [ __ ]
proven and I guarantee you like it was I
don't think he did I this is what I feel
I feel like Michael Jackson had a very
tumultuous childhood right because of
his father's a great word I don't thank
you after Google that later yeah
tumultuous childhood sounds like in the
context that it was a troublesome just
Chavez yeah just all right because it
sounds very much like it yeah but he had
that type of childhood and I think he
just like I think that dude honestly
just like kicking it with kids that's
what I feel like I feel like yeah I feel
like he wasn't looking they're [ __ ]
yeah I feel like he was just straight to
the licking ass yeah I think he was just
kicking it with it and if anything else
I feel like some of those kids were
hitting on him I'm putting it out there
I feel like this is what happened
Michael Jackson is chilling by himself
and he's hanging out with little Jeffrey
Jeffrey goes hey mr. Jackson so uh you
want to like kiss or something take this
a little [ __ ] out and the bubble grab
the kid he kicks him out of his house
yeah because he's afraid of careers you
want me to kiss you cooties
I'm still a baby baby yeah and that's
because I don't think nothing more
attractive to to like a seven-year-old
kid than a creepy look at Michael
Jackson at first I thought that Michael
Jackson might have but then when I kind
of looked at it I guarantee you I
there's something so innocent about
Michael I don't know why I dude I feel
like those kids probably said son to him
and Michael Jackson had a little Bobo of
the monkey
grab the kid by the ear to kick it so
it's tough to weather smoke there's fire
I think ooh you know that's that I think
I'll just say this it probably is more
likely than it is not you know your
dream killer dude
yeah but of joy that's what you are
you're it's like it's like but people
still appreciate how good is music what
I need to see evidence from the the FBI
or some [ __ ] of him having pictures with
these kids butt naked or so I don't need
to see the photos biggest thing I need
to know that they exist they could
Photoshop that for you
thank you figure something I don't know
man for some reason I'm going with my
gut feeling right now that Michael
Jackson did not do any what would he
what was the what's what's the proper
turn that I'm looking for baby penis
touching I'm pretty sure he didn't do
any of that [ __ ] I feel like he was just
say shading his childhood need to be
around kids cuz he thought he was a kid
because he doesn't seem like he thought
he was an adult it seemed like he was a
kid hanging out with other kids using
the word satiating with kids kind of
makes me feel word and talk about
Michael Jackson yeah well that's what
I'm gonna use right now because I'm but
I respected the I respect the Rankine
cycle II he knew he was an adult and he
was defiant teenage it was the funniest
thing to nobody like hanging around
teenage girls what do you consider it
and is like managers like don't say
anything he goes I got this define
teenager yeah was such confidence but
that's what probably gets him there
mmm-hmm like that's why he hasn't been
caught is because it's like the stone
cold face and he's like what I did was
he wrong did he just ask that is the
wrong I was when he said that [ __ ] I
started dying like the interviewer was
like did you really just [ __ ] say that
I died laughing I was in tears laughing
he said that [ __ ] but that's why I'm
saying like he was an adult that knew I
was like being a advantage of younger
kids yeah that's the difference and I
felt Michael Jackson was a dude that got
so [ __ ] up in the head that he still
believed he was a child
yeah so that's why I feel like they were
just kicking it and sharing lollipops of
[ __ ] just like that well it was it's
that level of abuse though it's like
you're the
there is a history of abuse that happens
probably which causes people to kind of
like he had sex with uh that lady and
had the baby
what was his wife's he was I thought it
was a test-tube blanket your tie my
blanket the mother a blanket that
child's name was blanket yeah that's
what I thought right you didn't know
he's either one that dangle he dangled
outside off the roof updating the Dingle
debated I think I think the baby's name
is blanket you're [ __ ] lying I'm
pretty sure I'm pretty sure but then
again I thought that'd be named the
child see I thought that was a test-tube
baby no well first of all that's only
that only proves what I said before no
he still thinks he's a kid he's a child
no imagine your dad as Michael Jackson
uh-huh like that Michael Jackson yeah
how [ __ ] up would you be you know uh
well I'll put it to you like this
that is only proof that Michael Jackson
is still a child because only a child
would name another child blanket yeah
you ask your three-year-old hey you're
gonna have a little sister coming yet or
you're [ __ ] crazy dude or you're just
a child the Fed this [ __ ] do you
understand me this is this is what it is
right this is what I win dude you win
you a year old kid right you ask your
three year old child hey mommy's gonna
have another kid it's going to be a
daughter what do you want to name the
kid lollipop boom that's that type of
answer Michael Jackson was a child I was
hanging out with other kids that's why I
had that's why he had never never touch
a kid land as much as I want to disagree
with you I think you won this one thank
you I think you won this one
I don't have nothing else to said I was
no rebuttals I was on your side I from
what I saw especially all the photos and
stuff that think that they released in
the investigation later on it really
made me think that he maybe did have
some kind of like sexual relationship
you know what we should do then you part
of this podcast it should be court case
review file time or something where we
look into or you look into I feel I feel
like I would do that and then people
will question my character because I'm
just defending everybody like what the
[ __ ] has David been doing something I I
wanted like as soon as I do defend
people too much because I try to give
people the benefit of doubt right like I
tried to
but you know it's it does get me in
trouble though only like I said the only
reason why I started to think that
Michael Jackson was innocent was because
of this our Kelly documentary - really
because he doesn't seem like the person
that was taking advantage of a young
person he just seemed like a guy that
was hanging out with his homies like he
was one of the sad life he was one of
the sad like kids but he didn't realize
he was old Sandlot kid would he be he
would jet he'd be the jet maybe he'd be
the jet yeah a hundred percent that's
what I would say no Sandlot dude I
[ __ ] no Sandlot II that's [ __ ]
crazy I was born in 92 what does Sam
lock him up [ __ ] like 98 oh no I did
it I think it came out way before that
dude dude I don't know look at you man
look at you I had older sisters oh you
know what your dad was in film yeah but
I could give this [ __ ] though I could
tell them yeah whatever dude yeah he
worked on [ __ ] Indiana Jones is that
crazy yeah your dad was actually has
like a short round my dad was short
round I'm just kidding he wasn't no he
had he had a lineage of great work he
has a crazy IMDB page that's what I'm
saying dude you come from greatness dude
what the [ __ ] happened to you you know
it's just trying to trash Michael
Jackson's name you piece of [ __ ] yeah no
I you know I'm a big fan of his music
and he's probably one of the only
artists see Michael Jackson song right
now that has a whole lot let me finish
this day cuz this is really important
that I get this out what phases take
this deal you wanna finish this I'm just
so hungry right now no I want to finish
the statement because he's probably one
of the only artists that has the past
that he has mm-hmm that people still
don't remember him for that as much yeah
but they do remember him for his good
music his amazing music do you miss body
of work that's what I'm saying you know
so now we're comparing Michael Jackson
to our Kelly you can't not do that
because he didn't have a sex cold he
just had a kindergarteners a
kindergarten class in his house do we
really know that though hey Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle put it the best
what'd he say all right Dave Chappelle
said how dared these [ __ ] kids come
over and [ __ ] blame him when he
invited them over had him pet all his
animals had him come to a play any suck
their dick
I'll [ __ ] get these kids rap map do
you remember the Chappelle show skit
where he's playing video games with a
kid that had cancer uh uh you don't
remember that I don't know that one okay
you guys I'm not gonna ruin it for you
guys cuz this is a really funny skit but
he's playing like the NBA 2k or
something yeah with this kid that has
cancer in the skit and it's [ __ ]
hilarious and it's not that long you
guys well you guys could find it you can
go back I didn't realize how many times
like like comedic shows made fun of the
Michael Jackson situation and the are
Kelly pissing on girls that you wish
their Airy spirits did a [ __ ] music
video on MADtv about him uh whatever
like like trying to like like like [ __ ]
little girls and also you know Dave
Chappelle did the [ __ ] are Kelly [ __ ]
yeah are Kelly bit I had no funny and I
feel like in the documentary they kind
of like made it seem that it wasn't okay
for them to make those jokes because it
made it so like trivial and not like a
real like I'm not a real issue did you
get that feeling too when you watched it
you know I it's kind of weird like I for
is it made me feel bad it made me feel
guilty because that I want to piss on
you was like that was a that was a big
part of my like life oh you know cuz it
was hilarious that was the jokes that we
would always make in like I didn't feel
bad about that I just think that what
would happen was I can't believe I don't
remember all this stuff like I remember
him going through the trial of him
pissing on the girl and everything else
but all the other stuff that they were
bringing up in terms of the the court
case that was televised and that was a
big [ __ ] deal but but think about
like when they rehash court cases is
that you only hear which you kind of
want to hear out of the news yeah like
you look at the Steven Avery stuff right
there yeah you murder documentary if if
people were going in depth that in depth
during the time of the court case yeah
we wouldn't really yeah be like we would
be in a different position and the same
with our Kelly stuff like if people
really knew what was going on because no
matter what goes on in the media you
take what you want to take out of it no
matter what like you watch them they
hear what you want to hear yeah you're
like always guilty of course
guilty and then but before like oh no
they're trying to bring him down like
[ __ ] dad they're haters or whatever like
ah that's the team that they play on but
unless there's any because I don't think
you can like disclose what the evidence
or what the yeas are but then if you do
most people don't want to hear it
yeah and it's like this is boring and
they just go back to kind of thinking
whatever they want to think that's
that's all that's how I feel we are
seeing like a very insane amount of
evidence just just pushed into one small
package it makes us feel a very certain
way exactly spread out a little more and
so it's easier for people to ignore
maybe that's why yeah that definitely
makes sense because I can't remember
half the stuff there and I and I loved
our Kelly dude and this fool there's so
many our Kelly songs that's ingrained
into my head that I didn't even realize
like obviously like ignition was a huge
thing that's that's the [ __ ] that's
when I if I am at a house party or stuff
like that and I hear that song everybody
knows what somebody yeah and I'm not
he's [ __ ] that night but now you're
gonna hear it and be like I heard a
sailor but I'm by 16% exactly like are
you gonna feel bad what are you cuz all
I can think about when I was watching
that documentary was and I want to hear
some more accounting song yeah I think
when they were talking about it but it's
so [ __ ] up though kind of you know but
when they were talking about how they
took all his music off to Spotify
Playhouse they were kind of making it
sound like and initially they were gonna
take him off Spotify or iTunes
completely and then in my mind I was
like I don't think that's really fair
there uh well they took him off the top
playlist and I was like okay I think
that's yeah that's definitely that it
really depends right so it kind of is
yeah it does depend but like my gut
instinct was like I don't know but then
it's hard like I don't want to think
about it because people how can you
listen to that monster it's like you
only say that because you didn't listen
to our Kelly when you were younger yeah
you don't and because it's sentimental
like it's it's we have different
memories of it they mentioned that in
the documentary that a lot of people
because his music was so influential a
lot of people attributed his music to a
very specific
of their life yeah whether it was at
their prom whether it was at their
wedding a lot of his music infiltrated
memories versus the actual music itself
and so that's why it became very
difficult to mute r.kelly and why people
would defend it because they weren't
really defending the human being they
were actually defending the memory that
was attached to a sentimental yeah and
that's the pup was like holy [ __ ] that's
right that's right if some people can't
like you know they can't put down some
of their comfort food yeah it goes back
full circle it's like yeah because it's
attached to so much memory and I'm like
I don't wanna have to like give that up
you know like people get like weird
about that yeah people who don't like
music either they're not gonna really
understand but yeah I could understand
it because I I only know every single
boys to men and Bryan Midnight Sun
because I got dumped once when I was 18
and I just had the show
[ __ ] repeat I was like these people
get a deal I bet she's so [ __ ] mad
that she dumped you no I was not well
you wish she wasn't that great of a
girlfriend either though so I'll put it
to you like that yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure she's doing fine
you're out - I'll get credit - no - any
bad on her no I don't ever wish bad upon
people that I broke up with she does he
does I absolutely do not I only wish the
best for her that [ __ ] she was a very
sweet girl and she even with her there's
because a specific time that I was with
her I was listening to number one
college dropout come on and jay-z
Blueprint come on and then all cylinders
right there yeah those were the two
biggest things that I would listen to
while I was going to class in my first
year at Riverside UC Riverside when I
hear those songs of bears it actually
reminds me of her yeah yeah so that's
that's the crazy that's what music does
those like and also a Corinne Bailey Rae
like oh dude oh my god those sisters
used to listen to that yeah your sisters
also you right yeah I did that's right
anything they liked I liked that what do
you guys do about pee breaks here huh
what do you guys what do you do about
pee breaks at genius Brant you [ __ ]
hold that [ __ ] it's gonna explode my pan
sir I want you to hold a [ __ ] can I just
go really quick and go go ahead you do
what every one of the fastest peers or
UUP [ __ ] you guys check the time
marker and when you pee and it doesn't
break the porcelain I'm gonna check
because I want to see how fast you I
peed my pants at H&M bathroom once
alright yeah but that's the thing about
music right like it there's definitely a
huge attachment that you have to it that
you kind of like dissociate yourself
from the artist so much I don't know
what it is you know what I'll put it to
you like this guys it feels we're
talking to myself and I'm just gonna
just keep rambling and I'm not gonna
pretend like this is this is comfortable
at all I absolutely refuse I could hear
him piss and it sounds like a water
stream is hitting a brick wall son of a
[ __ ] look could you go Nick look at
that and it sounds nice and full so I'm
thinking that the girth of his penis is
nice his penis might look like a laser
battery thick but very short yes oh he
comes out do you are a fast peer dude
that [ __ ] sounded vicious and angry I've
never heard of such a violent piss in my
life look at you just took out the [ __ ]
yeah dude I'm a violent [ __ ] peer for
sure it sounded like you were angry at
your penis and I am have you if you've
seen it you would be angry too if you
see my penis need to be very upset I'd
be very upset yeah look at that what
kind of shape is it that's shaped like a
[ __ ] squared Lego
it's and it has [ __ ] three bumps on
top of it like what is that it's a 90
degree angle he actually has to face the
hood he has a face sideways to the
[ __ ] toilet bowl so it goes in yeah
yeah I'm like that's why my lady is a
very special individual I'll tell you
this she does charity work a que se
custardy when I asked her to marry me a
hundred percent well guys we're gonna
probably wrap up the podcast you just
got we just started yeah did we how long
how long is that I think that's been
about an hour and 10 minutes alright
yeah that's why we had to redo it
because the first one was so slow you
were boring me to [ __ ] death was that
really you were so bad dude you're a
piece of [ __ ] as your big k we filmed a
little bit earlier and then we stopped
and he was like yeah you're doing great
I was like oh thanks man
well I do that well I do that like if
when I have children I need to build up
the confidence
so I need to lie to their [ __ ] face
dude it was you know what we talked
about art Kelly which was cool it's
funny because this guy is a personal
trainer he's soon to be Nasim's
certified a kinesiology major now not
know but sense yes yes player yes my bad
my bad
Counter Strike certified and then we
will talk about restricts yeah dude if I
could I would yeah hammer strike sir
we're trying to talk about stuff that's
you know something that he's really good
at then I mentioned about a man who
touches children and he lights up like a
[ __ ] Christmas tree well you know
what you talk about what's relevant you
know like you want to talk about this is
what's hot in the city this is this one
on the [ __ ] streets and I want to
know what you think about it this is
what I think about it these are my final
thoughts my final thoughts about that
number one are Kelly you can go to hell
number two Michael Jackson is innocent
that's what I think my final thoughts I
second what you said about our Kelly the
Michael Jackson stuff our Kelly made me
think that way too by the way
I didn't think about ya before prior
until I saw the death of Michael Jackson
stuff undecided well until further never
do a [ __ ] moonwalk I'm cutting your
Achilles heels
why because you could you shamed him
shaming Michael Jackson you know what
though it's hey pretty baby with the
high heels on come on you give me fever
like something something something
something huge Michael Jackson BAM yeah
that was actually the actual lyric you
are not alone I am still here with you
though we're far apart you're always in
my heart man and the mirror like changed
my life why just because the message is
so true
sing it a little bit right now if you
want to change the world you have to
change the person that's looking at you
in the mirror right so I got out to the
man in the mirror something something
something I just don't want to sing
because that you're you will get people
to unsubscribe to you immediate well
it's already happening as we speak
because they're highly disappointed
though shut up so that all the
unsubscribers out there you know
appreciate you guys for tuning in a
little bit and then unsubscribing after
you heard me talk you gave me a chance
you didn't like what you heard
and you left Lee so rightfully [ __ ] is
the tip actually get you that sweater
she did giving me this sweater and I
love it thanks you're full of [ __ ] it's
like I feel like this is more my vibe
it's like more like grandpa and like
honey it's like I like to do I actually
like your style a lot dude do you really
yes Matt is still the only dude I know
that still wears Nike Roshi's dude I
still love that it's for comfort I love
it dude do they do they jack up your
your your feet yeah they kind of do I
think I have plantar fasciitis I
guarantee you I because of Dunkel so
much in that [ __ ] I feel of roaches
though you know many times I've slipped
in the rain on them Oh too many to count
and in front of people that I know
people that I love even and you guys say
what size your feet I wear like a ten
damn you are ten I wear I've I have big
flat stupid feet and I have this
skinniest calves of all time I'm tiny
ankles I have small wrists I'm very
surprising you're a size 10 I have
dandruff what's up dude what is wrong
with you man I'm just I'm this is who I
am guys I'm just putting it out there
okay
this is me what you see is what you guys
do we end this podcast I want you to go
to a cemetery and then burying yourself
okay can you just do it for me and just
be a real pal no because then that would
just only enable your laziness you lazy
[ __ ] you know what though that's the
thing about you David so is that you
just go right to cuss words and that's
not how in fact I think that's lazy oh
really so because if I don't curse I
could hurt your feelings even more can
we go to the taco truck I like that we
curse because it's simple and then I
don't have to go into long descriptions
yeah kid let's just okay
watch this either you didn't have face
see easy you didn't have to you didn't
have to like yelling me I will co-host
all right that's it alcohol has lost all
my subscribers anyways guys we'll see
you next time
[ __ ] this guy thanks for having me guys